LeBron James being asked he's reading
the uh he's apparently reading the
autobiography of Malcolm X and he was
asked what his biggest takeaway from the
book was I don't know how far you are
into the book but what's your biggest
takeaway so far um I kind of just
started a couple days ago I've read and
a lot of a lot of notes over the years
it's my first time actually reading this
from start to finish c a
p but just a very
um his words in the in the 60s
and uh and what was going on is actually
what's going on today stop the C him
understanding the how powerful um The
Negro can
be but we have to unite you know things
that's going to be thrown at us where
they try to weaken us make us feel like
we're not kings and queens that guy is
the Camala Harris of the NBA what the
high hell did he say there every moment
in time and certainly this one to see
the moment in time